At the end of last school year, I got some surprising news, that a public school teacher that I knew named Cathy La Luz, was thinking of quitting teaching. It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass, by the way. I knew Cathy because before This American Life started, I was a reporter for NPR's news programs, Morning Edition and All Things Considered . And the thing that I reported on more than anything was education. Back in the 1990s, Chicago was going through the most ambitious school reform in the country. And as a reporter based out of Chicago, I spent lots of years in lots of classrooms all around the city.
上学年结束时，我听到一个令人惊讶的消息：我认识的一位公立学校老师凯西·拉·鲁兹（Cathy La Luz）正在考虑辞职。这里是《美国生活》（This American Life），我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。我认识凯西是因为在《美国生活》开播之前，我是美国国家公共电台（NPR）新闻节目《晨间报道》（Morning Edition）和《综合报道》（All Things Considered）的记者。我报道最多的主题就是教育。回到20世纪90年代，芝加哥正在经历全国最雄心勃勃的学校改革。作为驻芝加哥的记者，我花了很多年时间走访了全市各地的许多教室。
And I can say, hands down, that Cathy La Luz was the single best classroom teacher that I ever witnessed, and she taught at a great school. So last Spring, when I heard that she might quit, and that she might quit out of frustration, frustration with changes at her school, I visited her classroom. It was the day after school ended. She was packing up.
我可以毫无保留地说，凯西·拉·鲁兹是我见过的最优秀的课堂老师，而且她是在一所很棒的学校任教。所以去年春天，当我听说她可能要辞职，而且可能是因为沮丧而辞职——对学校发生的变化感到沮丧——我便去拜访了她的教室。那是学校放假的第二天，她正在收拾东西。
Seven, eight. There you go.
七，八。好了。
And I barely walked into her room and turned on the tape recorder when this happened.
我刚走进她的房间，打开录音机，就发生了下面这一幕。
I was saying that I told all my students that I might not be here next year, so if they wanted a letter of recommendation, they have to give me a letter now. So few of them took advantage of this. But what's funny is a domino effect, is they did it for every teacher. Just in case. They went to my partner. They went to the writing teacher. It was cute. It was cute. Excuse me. I'm sorry. I'm really sorry. Give me a minute.
我说过，我告诉所有的学生，明年我可能不会在这里了，所以如果他们想要推荐信，现在就得给我。只有很少的学生利用了这个机会。但有趣的是产生了连锁反应，他们向每一位老师都提出了同样的要求。以防万一。他们去找了我的搭档。他们去找了写作老师。这太可爱了。太可爱了。对不起。抱歉。真的很抱歉。给我一分钟。
Cathy, we haven't even started to talk.
凯西，我们还没开始谈呢。
I know. I know. I know.
我知道。我知道。我知道。
Is it just the thought of just not being back at all?
是因为想到以后完全不能回来了吗？
It is the thought of not being back, because I really love teaching. And then the other thing is I'm sad because I don't understand really how this could happen, in just a year, nine months. I don't see how this could happen so fast.
就是想到不能回来了，因为我真的很热爱教学。还有一点让我难过的是，我不明白这一切怎么会在一年、九个月的时间里发生。我不明白这一切怎么会发生得这么快。
For the changes this past year, Cathy's school, Washington Irving Elementary, was special in a couple ways. They weren't a magnet school, or charter school, or anything fancy like that. The staff at Irving wanted to prove that you could make school reform work at just a regular neighborhood school. At the start of reform, in fact, Irving was one of the worst schools in the system. But they moved into a brand new building, got an energetic new principal, and it doesn't get more symbolic than this, in 1988 the governor of Illinois signed school reform into law in the Irving gymnasium. TV coverage that night showed him under the unflattering fluorescent lights of the gym with a stack of pens and the thick legal document that was the school reform law.
对于过去一年的变化，凯西所在的华盛顿欧文小学（Washington Irving Elementary）在某些方面很特殊。它们不是重点学校、特许学校，也没有任何花哨的东西。欧文小学的教职员工想证明，在一所普通的社区学校也能搞好学校改革。事实上，在改革之初，欧文小学是系统内最差的学校之一。但他们搬进了一栋全新的大楼，迎来了一位充满活力的新校长，而且最具有象征意义的是，1988年伊利诺伊州州长就是在欧文小学的体育馆里签署了学校改革法案。那晚的电视报道中，他站在体育馆刺眼的荧光灯下，面前放着一叠钢笔和那份厚厚的学校改革法律文件。
Governor Thompson signed the measure into law in a special ceremony at the new Washington Irving Elementary School on South Oakley. When the reforms go into effect next July, one, school administration will be decentralized. Some of the power goes to parents and local school boards. Principals will be gaining more control over their own schools.
汤普森州长在南奥克利街的新华盛顿欧文小学举行的特别仪式上签署了该法案。明年7月改革生效后，第一，学校行政管理将实现去中心化。部分权力将下放到家长和当地校董会。校长将获得对自己学校更大的控制权。
OK. Fast forward five years. At the height of school reform in Chicago, I spent a full year at Irving Elementary, filing a story every few weeks for All Things Considered about how things were going there. In lots of ways, Irving became a real symbol of what could be done under reform. Test scores were moving up. Everything was getting better. They started with only a tiny fraction of their students, 15% doing reading and math at national standards. And it got to a point where 2/3 of their students were regularly at or above national standards. This is considerably better than most Chicago schools.
好的，快进五年。在芝加哥学校改革的高峰期，我在欧文小学待了整整一年，每隔几周就为《综合报道》发回一篇关于那里进展的报道。在很多方面，欧文小学成为了改革成效的真正象征。考试成绩在上升。一切都在好转。起初只有一小部分学生达到国家阅读和数学标准，占比15%。后来达到2/3的学生经常达到或超过国家标准。这比大多数芝加哥学校要好得多。
But things soured at Irving in the last year or so. The program that the Irving teachers created, the one that was so much more successful than the rest of the school system, was getting dismantled, piece by piece. Cathy started talking about quitting. Here's the reaction she got from a former principal at Irving, Pat Mizerka.
但在过去一年左右的时间里，欧文小学的情况恶化了。欧文教师们创造的那个项目，那个比学校系统中其他部分成功得多的项目，正在被一点一点地拆解。凯西开始谈论辞职。以下是她从欧文小学前校长帕特·米泽卡（Pat Mizerka）那里得到的反应。
I cried. I was so sad. I mean, Cathy is probably the best teacher that I've ever seen. And if she leaves, what hope is there, then, for the others?
我哭了。我太难过了。我是说，凯西可能是我见过的最好的老师。如果她走了，那其他人还有什么希望呢？
Cathy's classroom window looks directly out onto a commemorative plaque that says that this was the place where the nation's biggest school reform law was signed. Now that monument seems more like a tombstone.
凯西教室的窗户正对着一块纪念牌，上面写着这里是全国最大规模学校改革法案的签署地。现在，那座纪念碑看起来更像是一块墓碑。
School reform is dead. Everybody in the building, that's just what we say now. It's like if somebody has to complain about it, the way it is, someone will say, school reform's gone. Relax. It's over.
学校改革死了。大楼里的每个人现在都这么说。就像如果有人必须抱怨现状，总会有人说，学校改革没了。放松点，一切都结束了。
Today on our radio program, I'm going to take you back in time 10 years, and explain how Irving Elementary accomplished this thing that is so rarely accomplished in our country. They took a lousy inner-city school, and they turned it into a great school, with no special money, no special anything. They just did things smarter. And I'll explain what happened in just a year to set it back, how things got to a point where an exceptional teacher is now thinking about quitting. From Chicago Public Radio, you're listen to This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. Our show today in two acts. Act One, 1994. Act Two, 2004. Act One kind of gives you faith and hope in everything good. Act Two sort of, kind of, does the opposite. Stay with us.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我将带你回到10年前，解释欧文小学是如何完成了这个在我们国家极少能完成的事情。他们把一所糟糕的内城区学校变成了一所伟大的学校，没有特殊的资金，没有特殊的任何东西。他们只是更聪明地做事。我将解释在短短一年内发生了什么，导致它倒退，事情是如何发展到这一步，以至于一位优秀的老师现在考虑辞职。来自芝加哥公共广播电台，你正在收听的是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际（PRI）分发。我们今天的节目分为两幕。第一幕，1994年。第二幕，2004年。第一幕让你对所有美好的事物充满信念和希望。第二幕则正好相反。敬请收听。
Act One, 1994. OK. Let's roll some of the old tape from back in the days when I was a little sir.
第一幕，1994年。好的，让我们播放一些当年的老磁带，那时候我还是一位年轻先生。
This is All Things Considered . I'm Robert Siegel. This year, we're following the story of one school, Washington Irving Elementary, on Chicago's west side. Over the past few years this school has boosted reading scores with an innovative program. NPR's Ira Glass has our report.
这里是《综合报道》。我是罗伯特·西格尔（Robert Siegel）。今年，我们正在追踪芝加哥西区一所学校——华盛顿欧文小学的故事。在过去的几年里，这所学校通过一个创新的项目提高了阅读成绩。NPR的艾拉·格拉斯带来我们的报道。
The most striking thing about Washington Irving is that it's an unusually happy school. There's no other way to say it. Happy. When I ask eighth-grader Bianca Cannon to give me a little tour of the building--
华盛顿欧文小学最引人注目的地方在于，它是一所异常快乐的学校。没有别的说法。快乐。当我请八年级学生比安卡·坎农（Bianca Cannon）带我参观一下教学楼时——
OK, I'm just going to stop that right there. This is me in the present. I'm just going play you some old clips and some old stories right now. And a little background first, though, might be helpful. The idea behind the Chicago school reform was to let each school set education policy for itself, instead of some bureaucrats at the central office dictating everything the way they had in the past.
好了，我就在这里停一下。这是现在的我。我只是要播放一些旧片段和旧故事。不过，先交代一点背景知识可能会有帮助。芝加哥学校改革背后的想法是让每所学校自己制定教育政策，而不是像过去那样由中心办公室的官僚们发号施令。
And at Irving, they used that freedom to put in place a great reading program, and a great writing program. Both of them were based on a very common sense idea, that they should have kids read lots more than they were and write lots more than they were. More about that in a minute.
在欧文小学，他们利用这种自由实施了一个伟大的阅读项目和一个伟大的写作项目。这两者都基于一个常识性的想法：应该让孩子们比以前读更多书，写更多东西。稍后再详述。
The other thing they did was institute this kind of teaching that goes under different names. Student-centered curriculum, hands-on learning, holistic learning. The idea is, instead of a teacher standing at the chalkboard, lecturing and assigning chapters and questions from the textbook, and handing out dittos, students are more actively doing stuff. They're working in groups. They're doing projects. It's the kind of thing that good teachers do anyway, when they can. But at Irving, they went further with this idea than any school in Chicago. Teachers worked in teams. They had an hour of planning time every day to scheme out inventive lessons. And it worked. Kids liked it. Here are some eighth graders in Mr. Pearlstein's class back then.
他们做的另一件事是引入了一种有不同名称的教学法：以学生为中心的课程、实践学习、整体学习。其理念是，与其让老师站在黑板前讲课、布置章节和课本后的问题、分发练习卷，不如让学生更积极地参与。他们以小组形式工作，进行项目研究。这是好的老师在力所能及的情况下都会做的事情。但在欧文小学，他们将这一理念推得比芝加哥任何学校都远。老师们分组工作。他们每天有一小时的规划时间来构思富有创造力的课程。而且效果显著。孩子们很喜欢。看看当时珀尔斯坦（Pearlstein）先生班上的一些八年级学生。
In the back of the room, the two Veronicas sit next to each other. The Veronicas remember what it was like years ago at Irving, before they changed the curriculum. You read from a textbook. You answered questions in the back.
在教室后面，两个维罗妮卡（Veronica）坐在一起。她们还记得几年前在欧文小学课程改革之前是什么样子：读课本，回答后面的问题。
Read the books. Do the work in the books. It was mostly that. They gave you handouts and everything. So, I didn't really like it.
读课本。做书上的作业。大多是这样。他们给你发讲义之类的。所以我真的不喜欢。
Me neither, because it gets boring. It was boring every day. It's like the whole thing you did the day before. It was over and over and over every day. I hated it. But now every morning I really want to come to school. I want to come to school. I can't miss school.
我也不喜欢，因为太无聊了。每天都很无聊。就像前一天做的重复。每天都是没完没了地重复。我讨厌它。但现在每天早上我真的很想来学校。我想来学校。我不能缺课。
It wasn't always this way at Irving. Just a few years ago, it ranked in the bottom 100 schools in the city. Eighth graders who did their homework and participated in class were ridiculed by the other kids. And as in most Chicago schools, the longer a child stayed in school, the worse he was likely to do.
欧文小学并不总是这样。就在几年前，它在全市学校中排名垫底。认真写作业和参与课堂的八年级学生会受到其他孩子的嘲笑。而且和大多数芝加哥学校一样，孩子在学校待的时间越长，成绩往往越差。
Everyone always used to say, oh, God, by third grade, man, the glaze has come over the eyes.
大家总是说，天哪，到三年级的时候，伙计，眼神就变得呆滞了。
Irving principal, Madeleine Maraldi.
欧文小学校长玛德琳·马拉迪（Madeleine Maraldi）。
They've shut down on hearing, and speaking, and listening, and they don't care anymore.
他们已经不再听、不再说、不再听取意见，他们不再关心了。
Madeleine Maraldi began with the Chicago schools 33 years ago. She's the kind of principal that nearly everyone, even the school secretaries, calls by first name. Her management style tends toward group discussion and consensus building. In her six years at Irving, she and the faculty have rebuilt the curriculum around two main pillars. Students here read a tremendous amount each day in class, and students here write a tremendous amount each day in class. Writing, in fact, was the first thing the staff decided to tackle.
玛德琳·马拉迪33年前开始在芝加哥学校工作。她是一位几乎每个人，甚至连学校秘书都直呼其名的校长。她的管理风格倾向于集体讨论和共识建立。在她任职欧文小学的六年中，她和教职员工围绕两大支柱重建了课程。这里的学生每天在课堂上进行大量的阅读，每天在课堂上进行大量的写作。事实上，写作是教职员工决定的第一件要处理的事情。
I asked the teachers to come to consensus, to meet and come to consensus on what was the worst subject for the children? And they came up with writing, because they said, oh, they don't want to write, and when they write it's terrible, and they hate it, and it's too much work, and you don't get anywhere with it.
我要求老师们达成共识，开会并达成一致：对于孩子们来说最糟糕的科目是什么？他们认为是写作，因为他们说，噢，他们不想写，写出来很糟糕，他们讨厌它，这工作量太大了，而且练不出名堂。
The principal and teachers got retrained in a different style of teaching writing. Instead of emphasizing the mechanics of writing, like they used to, punctuation and paragraphing, and so on. The new method had kids first do lots of writing, learn to enjoy and invest in the writing, before they worry about mechanics.
校长和老师们接受了不同写作教学风格的再培训。不再像过去那样强调写作技巧，比如标点符号、分段等等。新方法是让孩子们先进行大量的写作，学会享受和投入写作，然后再担心技巧问题。
You can't be a writer unless you write. So when I say, then, let them write. They have to write every day. Let them write for journals. Let them write about their reaction to a math lesson. Write all kinds of things. Do writing all the time. And people would say, but I can't grade all of it. And I say, well, don't grade it. OK? Don't grade it.
除非你写，否则你成不了作家。所以我说，那就让他们写。他们必须每天都写。让他们写日记。让他们写对数学课的反应。写各种各样的东西。一直写。人们会说，但我改不过来这么多。我说，那就别改。好吗？别打分。
In fact, teachers were told emphatically, do not red-line every error in grammar and spelling. Do not discourage the kids. The results of the new program were immediate and dramatic, an outpouring of writing from Irving students.
事实上，老师们被明确告知：不要用红笔划出所有的语法和拼写错误。不要打击孩子们的积极性。新项目的结果是立竿见影且惊人的：欧文小学的学生写出了海量的文章。
OK. It's me again, in the present. Once the students got to sixth grade, that's when the teachers started grading them and teaching them the traditional mechanics of grammar and spelling and all that, in a very aggressive way. Then there was the reading program. There were studies showing that kids do better in school if they come from homes where people read to them, homes where they're encouraged to read themselves. Since most kids at Irving didn't come from homes like that, the staff decided to give them that experience during school time.
好了。现在又是现在的我。一旦学生升入六年级，老师们就开始给他们打分，并以非常积极的方式教授传统的语法、拼写等技巧。接着是阅读项目。有研究表明，如果孩子来自有大人给他们读书、鼓励他们自己阅读的家庭，他们在学校表现会更好。由于欧文小学的大多数孩子没有这样的家庭环境，教职员工决定在校期间给他们这种体验。
One afternoon, I happened to be sitting in Mr. Pearlstein's classroom, when his eighth graders came back from lunch. Watch this, he said. And I saw something that would be unimaginable in many city or suburban schools. Without any instructions from their teacher, the students filed into the room, quietly took out books, and read.
一天下午，我正好坐在珀尔斯坦先生的教室里，他的八年级学生刚吃完午饭回来。他说，看着。我看到了在许多城市或郊区学校都无法想象的事情。没有老师的任何指示，学生们安静地走进教室，拿出书，开始阅读。
They're on automatic pilot, and they just simply read because they enjoy reading. You'll notice that around the perimeter of the room we have hundreds of pocketbooks. You can see the bookshelves on the right hand. And whenever they feel the compulsion, they can simply get up and go and look for a book.
他们就像处于自动驾驶状态，只是单纯地阅读，因为他们享受阅读。你会注意到房间周围有数百本平装书。你可以看到右侧的书架。每当他们感到想读书时，他们就可以站起来去找书。
Every day, every class in this school does between 30 and 50 minutes of silent reading. Each of these eighth graders is required to read 2,800 pages, per semester, minimum. An A requires twice as many pages. It's a dramatic change from the old days. Principal Madeleine Maraldi says that when they first tried this approach five years ago, they learned just how little students had been reading, when one teacher received this complaint.
每天，学校里的每个班级都会进行30到50分钟的默读。每位八年级学生每学期至少要阅读2800页。获得A级需要阅读两倍的页数。这与过去相比是一个巨大的变化。玛德琳·马拉迪校长说，五年前他们刚尝试这种方法时，他们了解到学生以前读得太少了，因为一位老师收到了这样的抱怨。
This is painful. I can't take this. She says, what's the matter? Are you sick? And he goes, no. You're making me read for 50 minutes a day, all by myself. I can't do this. She says, you're in eighth grade. Get real. You can't read for 50 minutes a day? Kid says, no. I've been at Irving for eight years. Reading is you sit in your reading circle. You read a sentence or paragraph when the teacher calls on you, and you are finished with reading for the day.
这太痛苦了。我受不了了。她说，怎么了？你生病了吗？他说，没有。你让我每天独自读50分钟书。我做不到。她说，你都八年级了。清醒点。你不能每天读50分钟书？孩子说，不能。我在欧文小学待了八年。所谓的阅读就是你坐在阅读圈里。老师点到你时，你读一句或一段，你的阅读任务就完成了。
The only way to become comfortable reading is to practice, and this is why so many schools put so much effort into trying to change students' attitudes about books and reading. At Irving, this achieves the scale of a cultural war. Pro-reading propaganda posters and bookworm club certificates line the hallways. The phrase "Read, read, read, to succeed" is the school's mantra and its war cry, repeated so often that even the day before Christmas vacation, as kids said goodbye to their principal at the front door, they knew what she wanted to hear.
变得习惯阅读的唯一途径就是练习，这就是为什么这么多学校投入大量精力试图改变学生对书籍和阅读的态度。在欧文小学，这达到了文化战争的规模。支持阅读的宣传海报和书虫俱乐部证书挂满了走廊。“阅读，阅读，再阅读，以求成功”是学校的口号，也是它的战斗呐喊，重复的次数如此之多，以至于即使在圣诞假期前一天，孩子们在门口向校长道别时，他们也知道校长想听什么。
Can you say Merry Christmas to me?
能对我说声圣诞快乐吗？
Merry Christmas!
圣诞快乐！
And read--
还有阅读——
Read, read, read!
阅读，阅读，再阅读！
Thank you, Peter.
谢谢你，彼得。
Everything a book-loving parent would do for his child, teachers do here for these children. They read to the younger kids each day. Grant money buys each child books as gifts to keep. There are frequent trips to the public libraries, and regular class trips to bookstores, where students choose the books that they will share in their classrooms.
爱书的父母为孩子所做的一切，这里的老师都为这些孩子做了。他们每天给低年级的孩子读书。赠款资金购买书籍作为礼物送给每个孩子。这里有频繁的图书馆之旅，还有定期的班级书店之旅，学生们在那里挑选他们将在课堂上分享的书籍。
This one, please. Could I get this one?
请要这本。我可以拿这本吗？
All right. This is by the same author that wrote Bunnicula . I think that's fine.
好的。这是写《邦尼兔》（Bunnicula）的同一个作者写的。我想那没问题。
And can I read this one?
我可以读这本吗？
You're interested in Power Rangers, Joe?
你对《恐龙战队》（Power Rangers）感兴趣，乔？
On a trip to a big Barnes and Noble store, the Irving third graders are allowed to spend $4 each on a book. They check with their teachers.
在去巴诺书店（Barnes and Noble）的一次旅行中，欧文小学三年级的学生每人可以花4美元买一本书。他们会和老师核对。
Yes.
是的。
Is this $4?
这是4美元吗？
No. See? The price is right there. What does that say?
不。你看？价格就在那儿。上面写着什么？
$17.95.
17.95美元。
So, no. It's not $4.
所以，不。不是4美元。
The third graders aren't choosing great literature. It's Power Rangers and joke books, scary books, and mysteries. Older classes tend toward horror and teen romance. Their teachers point out that in addition to these trashy pleasures, the kids do read decent books in a regular literature class. The principal says that the fun of choosing books for themselves is part of what will turn them on to reading. Also--
三年级的学生选的不是什么文学名著。是《恐龙战队》、笑话书、恐怖书和推理小说。高年级学生倾向于恐怖和青少年浪漫小说。他们的老师指出，除了这些低俗的快乐，孩子们也会在常规文学课上读不错的书。校长说，自己挑选书籍的乐趣是激发他们阅读兴趣的一部分。而且——
They see other people in the bookstore. They see adults purchasing books. That's why I like to send them to the public libraries, also, because they see adults in the public libraries borrowing books. I think it's important that they see that there are other people out there doing these things.
他们在书店里看到了其他人。他们看到成年人在买书。这就是为什么我也喜欢送他们去公共图书馆，因为他们在公共图书馆里看到成年人在借书。我认为重要的是他们看到外面还有其他人也在做这些事情。
Since they began this program, reading scores have been climbing steadily at Irving. Depending on which standardized test you look at, the number of students reading at grade level has either doubled or quadrupled in five years. And it's instructive to note that in an era when politicians and educators often look for the quick fix for schools, teacher Joe Pearlstein says that it took three years of tinkering with the program and pushing kids, before he was seeing the kind of results he wanted.
自他们开始这个项目以来，欧文小学的阅读成绩稳步攀升。根据你参考的任何标准化考试，五年来阅读水平达到年级要求的学生人数增加了一倍或四倍。值得注意的是，在一个政治家和教育工作者经常寻找学校捷径的时代，教师乔·珀尔斯坦说，他花了三年时间对项目进行修补并督促孩子，才看到他想要的结果。
At times it was like hell. It was very difficult to do. You have to really be willing to invest the energy to overcome the storm.
有时简直像地狱。做起来非常困难。你必须真正愿意投入精力去克服风暴。
Hi. Me, again, today. This is one of the most interesting things that I found it Irving, was that even doing everything right, fixing the school was just incredibly slow work. They'd been at it for five years when I was there, and their test scores were only half of what they'd eventually become. It took another five years for them to get there. Remember, this is still an inner city school, with all the problems of any normal inner city school. Over 90% of the families were below the poverty level. Lots of kids in tough home situations. Absent parents. Gangs. Lots of Latino kids who enter kindergarten at Irving speak Spanish, not English.
嗨，今天又是现在的我。我在欧文小学发现的最有趣的事情之一是，即使做对了所有事情，修复学校的工作也非常缓慢。我在那里的时候，他们已经坚持了五年，他们的测试分数仅是他们最终水平的一半。他们又花了五年时间才达到那个水平。记住，这仍然是一所内城区学校，有着任何普通内城区学校的所有问题。超过90%的家庭低于贫困线。许多孩子处于艰难的家庭状况中。父母缺席。帮派。许多在幼儿园入学时说西班牙语而不是英语的拉丁裔孩子。
Well, of course, there's some kids who are better than others. Who do you want to see? You want to see a medium-type student?
当然，有些孩子比其他孩子好。你想看谁？你想看一个中等水平的学生吗？
To give you a sense of just what these teachers were up against, and how hard it was to make up for how badly these children had been taught in the past, here's the writing lab teacher, Judith Mensch. I asked her in one of my stories to show me a typical essay from one of the older students.
为了让你了解这些老师面临的挑战，以及弥补过去这些孩子被教得有多糟糕是多么困难，这是写作实验室老师朱迪思·门什（Judith Mensch）。我在一篇报道中请她向我展示一篇高年级学生的典型文章。
OK. This is a first draft in a longer project from the first marking period. Do you want me to read it?
好的。这是第一评分期一个较长项目的初稿。你想让我读一下吗？
"One day me and my friend was walking to the store. Then a big pit bull jumped out and started to chased us to the store. then he went back. I said, I hope that dog stay where it was. As soon as I said it, the dog chased us to my house. Then my auntie said, Get on away from here. The we don't see the dog, and dog don't see us. Come to find out, the was me Kisha dog."
“有一天我和朋友正走去商店。然后一只大比特犬跳了出来，开始追我们到商店。然后它回去了。我说，我希望那条狗待在原地。我刚说完，那条狗就追我们到我家。然后我阿姨说，离这儿远点。然后我们没看见狗，狗也没看见我们。结果发现，那是基莎（Kisha）的狗。”
Aside from the grammatical problems in the early sentences, and the pure mystery of that last sentence, there are punctuation problems. No quotation marks, no indenting of paragraphs. She's only able to move these students so far, so fast.
除了早期句子中的语法问题，以及最后一句完全是个谜之外，还有标点符号问题。没有引号，段落没有缩进。她只能让这些学生走得这么远，进步这么快。
And overall, when Ms. Mensch tried during the first marking period to hold these students to tougher standards in their mechanics, it didn't work. They didn't perform.
总的来说，当门什女士在第一评分期试图让这些学生达到更严格的写作技巧标准时，效果并不好。他们没有表现出来。
Madeleine was saying that the sixth grade hit the wall. They hit the wall. And I gave out a lot of incompletes, and stuff, and I caught a lot of heat for it, from the parents. And Madeleine basically said, back off. You're expecting too much. It's just too hard. Because they have so much to relearn.
玛德琳说六年级碰壁了。他们撞到了墙。我给出了很多未完成（incomplete）评分，诸如此类，我因此受到了家长们的猛烈抨击。玛德琳基本上说，退一步。你期望太高了。这太难了。因为他们有太多东西需要重学。
It's an interesting question, why, in the end Irving had so much more success than other public schools in Chicago. And a lot of the answer has to do with the way the principal, Madeleine Maraldi, implemented the changes. First off, she didn't force the changes on her teachers. When there was something new to try, she took volunteers. If it worked, other teachers signed up. And as reform progressed, the teachers met and they decided on the curriculum changes together, with Madeleine.
这是一个有趣的问题，为什么欧文小学最终比芝加哥的其他公立学校取得了更大的成功。答案很大程度上与校长玛德琳·马拉迪实施变革的方式有关。首先，她没有强迫她的老师做出改变。当有新的东西可以尝试时，她会招募志愿者。如果有效，其他老师就会加入。随着改革的推进，老师们开会，并与玛德琳一起决定课程改革。
The teachers felt like they were in charge of what was happening. Now this might not sound like a very big deal, but one of the most common reasons that school reform fails is a reason that you never hear about, in the press and in the normal political debate about how to fix schools. School reform often fails because teachers kill it. The teachers don't want to do it. They don't agree it'll work. They try it, it doesn't work at first. They fight among themselves, and it dies.
老师们觉得他们掌管着发生的一切。这听起来可能没什么大不了，但学校改革失败最常见的原因之一是你从未在媒体和关于如何修复学校的常规政治辩论中听到的：学校改革经常失败是因为老师们扼杀了它。老师们不想做。他们不同意它会奏效。他们尝试了，起初没用。他们在内部打架，改革就此夭折。
The year before I was at Irving, I spent a year at a Chicago high school, Taft High School, where the teachers started all kinds of changes, spent three quarters of a million dollars in grant money, but never came to agreement in four years about how to fix this school. And the bitter politics of all that wiped out the reform there. At the end of four years, the principal resigned. A lot of the pro-reform teachers resigned.
在我在欧文小学工作的前一年，我在芝加哥的一所高中——塔夫特高中（Taft High School）待了一年，那里的老师开始了各种各样的变革，花费了75万美元的赠款资金，但在四年里从未就如何修复这所学校达成协议。那种痛苦的政治斗争摧毁了那里的改革。四年结束时，校长辞职了。许多支持改革的老师也辞职了。
And it's not like Madeleine didn't face this problem at first. Remember, when she began, Irving was like any other public school, only a little worse. When she initially suggested making some changes at the school, teachers openly laughed at her. They said the reason kids performed so badly at Irving had nothing to do with the way that they were teaching.
而且玛德琳起初也不是没有遇到这个问题。记住，当她刚开始时，欧文就像任何其他公立学校一样，甚至还要更糟一点。当她最初建议在学校进行一些改变时，老师们公开嘲笑她。他们说，孩子们在欧文小学表现如此糟糕的原因与他们的教学方式无关。
It was everything out there. It was parents. It was the community. It was it was drugs. It was teen pregnancies. It was violence. It was gang activity. It was everything outside this building. Those were the reasons why. So that's how it started.
那是外面的一切。是家长。是社区。是毒品。是青少年怀孕。是暴力。是帮派活动。是大楼外的一切。这就是原因所在。事情就是这样开始的。
As the reforms progressed, three Irving teachers transferred to other schools. It took the rest of the teachers, Madeleine says, a year before they even started to trust her. And she slowly won people over and built her team, to the point where word got out what a special place Irving Elementary was. A place where teachers were encouraged to try new things. A place that set higher standards than the school board had. Really good teachers started to transfer to Irving when vacancies came up, like Cathy La Luz, who we started this program with. She was such an interesting teacher to watch that one of my stories for All Things Considered was simply a typical Friday in her classroom. Here's a big chunk of that story.
随着改革的推进，三名欧文小学的老师转到了其他学校。玛德琳说，剩下的老师花了一年时间才开始信任她。她慢慢赢得了人们的支持，建立了她的团队，直到欧文小学成为了一个特殊的去处。一个鼓励老师尝试新事物的学校。一个设定了比教育委员会更高标准的学校。优秀的老师在出现空缺时开始转到欧文小学，比如我们节目开头提到的凯西·拉·鲁兹。她是一位非常有趣的老师，值得一看，我为《综合报道》写的报道之一就是关于她课堂上一个典型的周五。这是那篇报道的一大段。
Great ball players, and great musicians, make the remarkable look easy. And great teachers do that too.
伟大的球手和伟大的音乐家让非凡的事情看起来很简单。伟大的老师也是如此。
Do you like my hair today? I thought you would, Tracy.
你喜欢我今天的发型吗？我想你会的，翠西（Tracy）。
The school day begins at 10 minutes before 9:00. Miss La Luz picks up her kids in the gym and then brings them to the classroom.
上课时间是9点前10分钟。拉·鲁兹小姐在体育馆接她的孩子，然后把他们带到教室。
No, we don't need the lights today, do we, guys?
不，我们今天不需要开灯，对吧，伙计们？
Part of what makes Miss La Luz such a good teacher is her classroom manner. She seems utterly relaxed, happy, in control, calls the kids baby, sweetheart, angel, and, in Spanish, miho and miha. Most people seem to become someone else when they stand in front of a classroom, like they're playing a character in a drama. Miss La Luz seems like herself.
拉·鲁兹小姐之所以成为好老师，部分原因在于她的课堂管理方式。她看起来非常放松、快乐、有掌控力，称呼孩子们为“宝贝”、“甜心”、“天使”，并用西班牙语称呼“miho”和“miha”。大多数人在站在教室前时似乎变成了另一个人，就像在戏剧中扮演一个角色。拉·鲁兹小姐看起来就像她自己。
What did I do?
我做了什么？
You got some different earrings on.
你换了不同的耳环。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉的声音]
You got a new hairstyle.
你换了新发型。
New shirt!
新衬衫！
Everybody's right. New shirt. Kendel noticed my earrings. And somebody noticed Miss La Luz's new haircut, which is only going to last for today. All right, take our seats.
大家都对了。新衬衫。肯德尔（Kendel）注意到了我的耳环。有人注意到了拉·鲁兹小姐的新发型，这只保持到今天。好了，坐好吧。
Very sharp. Very sharp.
真时髦。真时髦。
The philosophy of this school is to motivate students with all sorts of active lessons, where the children do projects and express their ideas. The fifth graders' day usually begins with half the kids going to writing lab, where they each write on computers, and half the kids staying for literature, where they read and discuss books in groups of four. Next is math. Last Friday, Miss La Luz had a hands-on activity to help students understand one of the hardest and most abstract ideas in fifth grade math, fractions.
这所学校的理念是用各种活跃的课程来激励学生，让孩子们做项目并表达他们的想法。五年级学生的一天通常从一半孩子去写作实验室开始，他们在电脑上写作；另一半孩子留在文学课，四人一组阅读和讨论书籍。接下来是数学。上周五，拉·鲁兹小姐进行了一项实践活动，帮助学生理解五年级数学中最难、最抽象的概念之一：分数。
OK, you cut it into two pieces, OK? Now, do you understand why this is a half? What does half mean?
好的，你把它切成两块，好吗？现在，你明白为什么这是二分之一吗？一半是什么意思？
Students spent an hour cutting construction paper into fractions, halves, quarters, eighths, and sixteenths, preparing actually for a fractions game. Miss La Luz circulated, and helped kids one-on-one.
学生们花了一小时将建筑纸剪成二分之一、四分之一、八分之一和十六分之一，实际上是在为分数游戏做准备。拉·鲁兹小姐在课间巡视，一对一地帮助孩子。
What is this? This number means this is one piece out of two, that there's two pieces all together, and this one says here's one piece out of two. If I showed you something and said one piece out of 16, how many pieces are there altogether? How many slices were the pie cut into?
这是什么？这个数字意味着这是两块中的一块，一共两块，这一个说这里是两块中的一块。如果我给你看个东西说十六分之一，总共有多少块？馅饼被切成了多少片？
16.
16片。
Right.
对。
Now, as good as all this sounds, Miss La Luz says that about a third of her students aren't doing math as well as they should. And however wonderful a teacher she is, keeping everyone on task still means prodding the stragglers into action here and there. There aren't too many, one every five minutes or so.
现在，虽然这一切听起来很好，但拉·鲁兹小姐说她班上大约有三分之一的学生数学做得不如他们应该做的好。无论她是一位多么出色的老师，让每个人都专注任务仍然意味着不时要鞭策掉队的人。人数并不多，每五分钟左右一个。
This doesn't look finished.
这看起来没做完。
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
Come to the hallway. You are clearly not paying attention, all right? What are you supposed to do once you fold those pieces?
到走廊来。你显然没在注意听，好吗？你折完那些碎片后应该做什么？
Cut them.
剪开它们。
Have you done that, darling?
你做了吗，亲爱的？
No. And, if you don't know what to do next--
没。而且，如果你不知道接下来做什么——
I pretty much know who needs the nudge, but as long as I don't do it in a disrespectful manner. It has to be a nudge. It has to be, come on, you know what to do. That's why I say "you know what to do." You know. It's not, "Do it! You're supposed to do it!" It's "You know what to do. Do it."
我基本上知道谁需要推动，只要我不以不尊重的方式去做。那必须是一个推动。必须是，“来吧，你知道该怎么做。”这就是为什么我说“你知道该怎么做”。你知道。而不是“快做！你应该做的！”而是“你知道该怎么做。去做吧。”
Baby, did you do something inappropriate? What'd you do?
宝贝，你做了什么不合适的事吗？你做了什么？
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
If I was aggressive, if I was saying, come on, you're not doing your work. What's wrong? What's wrong? They won't get involved at all. They totally disengage. They do what they're supposed to do, only, and they won't get involved in the process. It's meaningless. It's, OK, what steps do I have to follow? You're making me do it, I'll do it, fine. If you make me. I'm not interested in making you. I'm interested in-- almost like-- this is going to sound funny, but almost like a seduction. Almost like a, come on, come on, luring them. You know what you're supposed to do, and appealing to the good in them.
如果我很咄咄逼人，如果我说，快点，你没在做作业。怎么了？出什么问题了？他们根本不会参与。他们会完全脱离。他们只会做他们被要求做的事情，而不会参与到过程中。这毫无意义。这变成了，好吧，我必须遵循什么步骤？是你逼我做的，我就做，好吧。如果你逼我。我不感兴趣逼你。我感兴趣的是——听起来很有趣——几乎像是一种诱惑。几乎像是，来吧，来吧，吸引他们。你知道你该做什么，并呼吁他们善良的一面。
Now, baby. Now I'm really concerned about something. Turn around, my angel. What am I concerned about [INAUDIBLE]. Can you tell?
现在，宝贝。现在我真的很担心某件事。转过身，我的天使。我担心什么[听不清]。你能告诉我吗？
About what I said. I would talk [INAUDIBLE].
关于我说的。我会谈谈[听不清]。
Yeah, I know you weren't really talking to me. And I also know you would never be rude on purpose to me. I know that you're a sweetheart. I know that. But--
是的，我知道你不是真的在跟我说话。我也知道你永远不会故意对我无礼。我知道你是个甜心。我知道。但是——
I think that's the mistake a lot of teachers make. They don't appeal to the good in the kid. You know what to do, sweetheart. Do it. That's way more powerful than, you better do it because you have to. You're going to fail. Fine, I'm a failure. Fine. Leave me alone.
我认为那是很多老师犯的错误。他们没有呼吁孩子善良的一面。你知道该怎么做，甜心。去做吧。这比“你最好做，因为你必须做。你会失败的。”更有力得多。好吧，我是个失败者。好吧。别管我。
With some prodding, most of the class is energetically engaged for most of math. As they cut their fraction strips, the kids nearest to me happily chatter away about the Forrest Gump episode of Blossom , and whether Montel Williams is better than The Richard Bay Show.
在一些鞭策下，大多数学生在大部分数学课上都充满活力地参与。当他们剪分数条时，我旁边的孩子们愉快地聊着《绽放》（Blossom）里关于《阿甘正传》（Forrest Gump）的那集，以及蒙特尔·威廉姆斯（Montel Williams）是否比《理查德·贝秀》（The Richard Bay Show）更好。
Miss La Luz herself is a graduate of the Chicago public schools, grew up in a tough Puerto Rican neighborhood, and says that she wanted to teach partly because she had so few good teachers herself. At the heart of Miss La Luz's classroom practice is the notion that she wants her students to feel respected, and to feel that their ideas are worthwhile. The day I visited, during their discussion of the book The Bridge to Terabithia, she tried to get them to talk about a point in the book that struck a chord with her, but realized after a few minutes that they weren't going with it. And listen to where they were taking the discussion, namely some alternate endings that they would prefer to the book. She changed their writing assignment to accommodate this.
拉·鲁兹小姐本人是芝加哥公立学校的毕业生，在波多黎各人的艰苦社区长大，她说她想教书部分是因为她自己遇到的好老师太少了。拉·鲁兹小姐课堂实践的核心是她希望她的学生感到被尊重，并感到他们的想法是有价值的。我拜访的那天，在他们讨论书籍《通往特雷比西亚桥》（The Bridge to Terabithia）时，她试图让他们谈论书中一个触动她的点，但几分钟后意识到他们并没有打算往那方面谈。听听他们把讨论带到了哪里，即他们更喜欢书中一些替代的结局。她改变了他们的写作作业以适应这一点。
I was going to do a journal response about something else, but you guys already know where you want to go. So if you know want a different ending, or more information, why don't you put down what you wished you could see next in the story.
我本来要做关于其他事情的日志回复，但你们已经知道你们想往哪里走了。所以，如果你知道想要一个不同的结局，或者更多信息，为什么不写下你希望在故事中看到什么呢。
All right!
好的！
[INAUDIBLE] journal response.
[听不清] 日志回复。
Studies show that only 40% to 60% of a school day, in cities and suburbs, is spent in actual instruction. The rest of the time is spent settling down, getting materials ready, giving instructions, taking attendance, moving through the halls, lunch, you can imagine. Miss La Luz is as efficient as any teacher. The day I visited, her class spent about two and a half hours on hard core academic subjects, and another hour and a quarter on various other subjects, band, media arts, gym, counseling. Anyone who learned their fractions in grammar school could tell you that this works out to about 2/3 of the school day spent in instruction. It was low for Miss La Luz, because she decided to forego the usual hour of project time that ends the day, so the kids could end their week joyfully, singing, and then playing outside.
研究表明，城市和郊区的学校，只有40%到60%的学校时间用于实际教学。其余时间花在安定下来、准备材料、给出指示、考勤、走廊行走、午餐，你可以想象一下。拉·鲁兹小姐和任何老师一样高效。我拜访的那天，她的班级花了大约两个半小时在核心学术科目上，又花了一个半小时在其他各种科目上，乐队、媒体艺术、体育、咨询。任何在小学学会分数的人都会告诉你，这相当于大约2/3的学校时间用于教学。这对拉·鲁兹小姐来说很低，因为她决定放弃每天结束时通常的一小时项目时间，这样孩子们就能欢快地结束这一周，唱歌，然后在外面玩耍。
I hope we're ready. De Andre? Looks like you need a partner, baby. Come to me.
希望我们准备好了。迪安德烈（De Andre）？看起来你需要个搭档，宝贝。到我这儿来。
It was the kind of song with funny choreography that went with it. Even the most reserved of the boys played along, sang and danced, and left school last Friday wanting to come back, just as their teacher hoped for. I'm Ira Glass, in Chicago.
那是那种配有有趣舞蹈动作的歌曲。即使是最矜持的男孩也参与其中，唱歌跳舞，并像他们的老师所希望的那样，在上周五愉快地离开学校。我是艾拉·格拉斯，在芝加哥。
[SINGING]
[唱歌]
OK. What kind of moronic policies would you have to put in place to make that teacher think about quitting? We jump forward 10 years in just one minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
好的。你必须制定什么样的愚蠢政策，才能让那位老师考虑辞职？我们在一分钟后快进10年。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. If you're just tuning in, all this hour we're hearing the story of an unusually good public school. But in the last year or so that school has gone through some changes. Parts of the program that made it one of the most successful schools in Chicago are being dismantled, and it's gotten to the point where one of the best teachers in the school, who you heard just before the break, Cathy La Luz, is thinking about quitting teaching.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。如果你刚收听，整个小时我们都在听一所异常优秀的公立学校的故事。但在过去的一年左右，那所学校经历了一些变化。使它成为芝加哥最成功学校之一的项目部分正在被拆解，甚至到了学校里最优秀的老师之一——你在休息前听到的那位凯西·拉·鲁兹——正在考虑辞职的程度。
So, what happened? Well, a couple things changed in the 10 years since I first visited Irving Elementary. First, the matriarch behind the changes at Irving, Madeleine Maraldi, retired. Fortunately, there was somebody on staff who was trained and ready to step in as her successor, Pat Mizerka, who'd been a seventh grade teacher in the school, then Assistant Principal. She'd been there through most of the changes. If anything, the school got even better under Pat Mizerka. Test scores climbed higher, partly thanks to a tutoring program that the central school board provided the school, and partly, she says, for a reason that is completely surprising.
那么，发生了什么？好吧，自我也第一次拜访欧文小学以来的10年里，发生了一些变化。首先，欧文小学变革背后的女家长玛德琳·马拉迪退休了。幸运的是，员工中有人受过训练并准备好接替她的继任者，帕特·米泽卡，她曾是学校的七年级老师，后来担任助理校长。她经历了大部分变革。如果说有什么不同的话，学校在帕特·米泽卡的领导下变得更好了。测试成绩更高了，部分归功于中央校董会为学校提供的辅导项目，部分归功于她所说的另一个完全令人惊讶的原因。
Glasses.
眼镜。
That's right.
没错。
Glasses. Unbelievable, right? Unbelievable. We had a dean of students, Mr. Pearlstein, and he was on top of this. Every child who should be wearing glasses will be wearing glasses.
眼镜。难以置信，对吧？难以置信。我们有一位学生主任，珀尔斯坦先生，他负责这个。每个应该戴眼镜的孩子都会戴上眼镜。
How many kids ended up having to get glasses?
有多少孩子最终不得不配眼镜？
Oh, I would say between 30% to 40% of our student body wore glasses.
噢，我会说我们学生群体的30%到40%戴眼镜。
At the end of the process, that is. Grant money paid for the glasses. But during Pat Mizerka's time as principle, the central office of the Chicago Schools started to issue orders, each of these orders small, each of them well-meaning, each of them in a certain way so tiny that, by themselves, they didn't mean all that much. But added up together, they pulled down some of the underpinnings of what Irving Elementary had built.
过程结束时是这样。赠款支付了眼镜费用。但在帕特·米泽卡担任校长期间，芝加哥学校的中心办公室开始下达命令，每一个命令都很小，每一个都是出于好意，每一个在某种程度上都如此微小，以至于它们本身并不意味着什么。但加在一起，它们推倒了欧文小学所建立的根基。
One of the first things to go was the Irving report card. Over the course of a decade, Irving teachers had designed this report card that, in addition to all the regular grades, had a space where students evaluated themselves. Which most kids took very seriously, which was part of getting them to take responsibility for their own work. Pat Mizerka had to deliver the news to the Irving staff, that they'd been ordered to do a report card like the rest of the school system.
最早消失的东西之一是欧文小学的成绩单。在十年间，欧文的老师们设计了这张成绩单，除了所有的常规成绩外，还有一个空间让学生进行自我评价。大多数孩子非常认真地对待这一点，这是让他们承担自己工作责任的一部分。帕特·米泽卡不得不向欧文的员工传达这个消息，他们被要求使用和学校系统其他部分一样的成绩单。
Oh, they were very upset. And so then I had to relay that the board was looking for uniformity, and they wanted all schools to have the same report card, because when children transfer from one school to another, it's hard, then, for another school to-- if they're not using the same report card-- then to mesh the grades together.
噢，他们非常沮丧。所以我不得不传达董事会寻求统一的消息，他们希望所有学校都有相同的成绩单，因为当孩子从一所学校转到另一所学校时，如果他们不使用相同的成绩单，那么——那么合并成绩就很难。
This wasn't so convincing to the Irving teachers. The Irving report card evaluated students on the specific things being taught, the number of pages they read, the specific reading skills they did and did not have, in much more depth than the standard Chicago report card. The Irving report card didn't have a D grade. Irving teachers didn't believe in the D, that there should be a grade that admits that, you didn't learn the material, but you should still pass. In short, Irving teachers were giving up a tougher report card for one that held kids to lower, vaguer standards.
这对欧文小学的老师来说说服力不强。欧文的成绩单评估了学生所教的具体内容、他们阅读的页数、他们具备或不具备的具体阅读技能，比标准的芝加哥成绩单深入得多。欧文的成绩单没有D级。欧文的老师不相信D级，不认为应该有一种成绩承认你没有学到材料，但你应该通过。简而言之，欧文的老师为了一个让孩子保持更低、更模糊标准的成绩单而放弃了一份更严厉的成绩单。
I remember the shock, and we just sat there. It was just this quiet.
我记得那种震惊，我们只是坐在那里。只有这种安静。
Which brings us back to Cathy La Luz. She remembers when Pat Mizerka gave them all the news.
这把我们带回了凯西·拉·鲁兹。她记得帕特·米泽卡告诉他们一切消息的时候。
I was just, this just can't be. Just erase this? We've been making this report card for, what? 12, 13 years? And we couldn't believe we didn't have a choice. There's that weird feeling of all of a sudden, there's no choice. There's no negotiating, no how about if we say this? And I remember Pat just saying to us, just, no.
我当时简直是，这不可能。就这样抹去？我们一直在制作这张成绩单，什么？12、13年了？我们无法相信我们没有选择。那种奇怪的感觉是突然间，没有选择了。没有谈判，没有“如果我们这样说怎么样？”我记得帕特只是对我们说，不。
Before long, the Irving teachers lost something else, something that was at the very heart of their education program.
没过多久，欧文的老师们失去了别的东西，处于他们教育项目核心的东西。
And number 4,732. Who's next? What number are you? Number seven?
还有4,732号。下一个是谁？你是几号？七号？
Over the course of years, the Irving teachers had developed a system where three times a year, every parent had to come in with their child, for an appointment to meet with the teacher and go over their report card. It took a full day and a half, each time they did it. But, the teachers said, it meant everything to get to know the parents this way, and to get them this involved in overseeing their children's education. Seeing it in action, it was hard to imagine why every public school didn't do it. Here's a section of a story that I did 10 years ago about it.
多年来，欧文的老师们开发了一个系统，每年三次，每个家长必须带着他们的孩子来预约与老师见面，并检查他们的成绩单。他们每次这样做都需要整整一天半的时间。但是，老师们说，通过这种方式了解家长，并让他们参与到监督孩子的教育中来，意义重大。看着它的实际效果，很难想象为什么每所公立学校都不这样做。这是我10年前做的一段关于它的报道。
In room 306, the two eighth grade teachers sit at separate tables. The teachers' strategy is this. Do not blame the parent, but make the child realize it's his responsibility to do the work, and get the parent to reinforce this. Mr. Paul begins his conference with Cornell Miller with a time-honored teacher technique you may remember from your grade school days. He tells Cornell to explain his bad grades to his mom.
在306教室，两位八年级老师坐在不同的桌子旁。老师的策略是：不要责怪家长，但要让孩子意识到做功课是他的责任，并让家长加强这一点。保罗先生（Mr. Paul）以一种你们可能还记得小学时代的那种老师的老派技术开始了与康奈尔·米勒（Cornell Miller）的会议。他告诉康奈尔向他妈妈解释他不好的成绩。
Reading. What didn't happen for you to get an incomplete?
阅读。什么没发生导致你得了未完成（incomplete）？
I didn't read. Well, I read, but I had [? an intermediate ?] for the second marking period, and I had to read for this marking period.
我没读。好吧，我读了，但在第二个评分期我有[？一个中间水平？]，而这一评分期我必须阅读。
Was there a different way you could do this?
有没有别的方法你可以这样做？
Yeah.
有。
Would you share that with us?
愿意和我们分享吗？
I didn't read all the books. That's all.
我没读完所有的书。就是这样。
You didn't read all the books. OK, well, why didn't you read all the books?
你没读完所有的书。好吧，为什么你没读完所有的书？
I don't know.
我不知道。
He never have a answer for that.
他从来没有答案。
Those three report card pick-ups, where parents have to come in with their child, that structure matters. I think that structure is part of our success.
那三次成绩单领取，家长必须带孩子来，那种结构很重要。我认为那种结构是我们成功的一部分。
Again, here's Cathy La Luz, in the present.
再次，这是凯西·拉·鲁兹，现在的。
Because, you know, what happened one year, we didn't do it. This is before things were going downhill. Some teachers were really, why do this? So one year we didn't do it. We saw drops. Like the reading program that we have, less books being read, less reading happening, less homework coming in to me. Watching the work ethic go downhill in terms of what was coming to us. We had this long talk at the end of the year, where I remember, Pat was a teacher at the time. And she was the first one to say, this was awful. And then you heard other voices. Everybody, wow. What a drop in just taking the classes seriously. We can't do this again.
因为，你知道，有一年发生的事情是，我们没做。这是在事情走下坡路之前。一些老师真的很想，为什么要这样做？所以有一年我们没做。我们看到了下滑。就像我们有的阅读项目，书读得少了，阅读量少了，交给我的作业少了。看着职业道德在交给我们的东西方面走下坡路。我们在年底有一次长时间的谈话，我记得，帕特当时还是老师。她是第一个说，这太可怕了。然后你听到了其他声音。每个人，哇。对认真对待课程的下滑太大了。我们不能再这样了。
But this year, thanks to a minor rule change in the central school board, Irving has to give out report cards the way that all other schools do. Instead of a total of four and a half days devoted to parent conferences, they'll have one day. Cathy's prediction?
但今年，多亏了中央校董会的一个微小规则改变，欧文小学必须以所有其他学校的方式分发成绩单。而不是总共四天半的时间用于家长会，他们只有一天。凯西的预测？
If I was going to predict, I predict that what happened that time will happen again. We'll see less output, less parent involvement, less connection with the parent.
如果我要预测，我预测那时候发生的事情会再次发生。我们将看到产出减少，家长参与减少，与家长的联系减少。
Last year, after two years as principal, Pat Mizerka had to leave the principal's job for personal reasons. She was replaced by somebody named Rita Ortiz, who came from outside Irving. Very quickly, this new principal got off on a bad foot with the teachers, by insisting on something so basic that she never suspected it could be controversial. Rita Ortiz asked that they turn in lesson plans.
去年，担任校长两年后，帕特·米泽卡因个人原因不得不离开校长职位。她被一个叫丽塔·奥尔蒂斯（Rita Ortiz）的人取代，她来自欧文小学之外。很快，这位新校长就因为坚持一些如此基础的东西而与老师们关系不佳，她从未怀疑这会有争议。丽塔·奥尔蒂斯要求他们提交教案。
At Irving School, we never had to write formal lesson plans.
在欧文小学，我们从不需要写正式教案。
Again, Cathy La Luz.
再次，凯西·拉·鲁兹。
It was, if you like writing formal lesson plans, go ahead. If you like taking notes, go ahead. If you just keep a diary, and my principal read it. You want to show me that? Go ahead. Whatever works for you in planning your day. Your style is your style. Just prove to me that it works.
那是，如果你喜欢写正式教案，那就去吧。如果你喜欢记笔记，那就去吧。如果你只是记日记，我的校长读了它。你想向我展示吗？那就去吧。无论什么适合你规划你的一天。你的风格就是你的风格。只要向我证明它有效。
There was a meeting where she announced that we needed to do lesson plans, and she wanted them every-- I believe it was every Friday.
有一次会议她宣布我们需要做教案，她希望他们每个——我相信是每个周五。
Heather Madden teaches Special Ed at Irving.
希瑟·马登（Heather Madden）在欧文小学教特殊教育。
It was a horrible reception. The gasps and, oh my goodness. The rustling of the papers, and just feel the tension in the air. It was horrifying.
这是一个可怕的接待。喘气声和，噢天哪。纸张的沙沙声，只是感觉到空气中的紧张。这太恐怖了。
Typically decisions at Irving had been made in a democratic manner. If there was something new that was going to be taken on, it was always not necessarily brought to a vote. Many times it was brought to a vote. But typically it was discussed in an open forum, and we all got our opinions out and really hashed it out, and come to a conclusion that was agreeable between everyone.
通常欧文的决定是以民主方式做出的。如果有新的东西要承担，并不一定需要投票。很多次它是通过投票决定的。但通常它是在一个开放的论坛中讨论的，我们都表达了我们的意见，真正地把它搞清楚，并得出一个每个人都赞同的结论。
From Principal Rita Ortiz's perspective, this really wasn't the kind of thing that bore any discussion. Every school in the system had been ordered to do lesson plans. Irving would do lesson plans. Here's Rita Ortiz.
从丽塔·奥尔蒂斯校长的角度来看，这真的不是那种值得讨论的事情。系统中的每所学校都被要求做教案。欧文小学将做教案。这是丽塔·奥尔蒂斯。
Plans are a part of the teacher observation sheet that a principal, or another administrator involved in classroom observation, uses. It's one of the criteria in observing a teacher.
计划是校长或参与课堂观察的另一位管理人员使用的教师观察表的一部分。这是观察老师的标准之一。
So, were you surprised at the reaction?
所以，你对这个反应感到惊讶吗？
I was. Coming from a background where not only did I do them, I saw everyone else do them in various situations.
我是。来自一个背景，不仅我做了它们，我还看到其他人在各种情况下做它们。
I'm sure to Rita, it was just format. It was it was the way things were done. And I understand that. But at the same time, it was really disheartening to watch the atmosphere of the school change, and the atmosphere of the staff change, so quickly.
我肯定对丽塔来说，这只是格式。这是事情完成的方式。我明白。但同时，看着学校的气氛变化，教职员工的气氛变化如此之快，真的很令人沮丧。
The heart of this change was that the staff wasn't used to being ordered to do things. When the school board would mandate something, like formal lesson plans, the teachers in the past would sit down together with the principal and figure out how to respond.
这种变化的核心是员工不习惯被命令做事。当校董会强制规定一些事情时，比如正式教案，过去的老师会和校长坐下来一起想出如何回应。
We would come up with something that would meet the board's requirements, but also meet the philosophy and the practices that had always occurred at Irving.
我们会想出一些能满足董事会要求，同时也符合欧文一直以来的理念和实践的东西。
And did anybody say to her, look, the way that we usually do this is if the board asks you to do some like this, we talk about it and come up with a solution together?
有没有人对她说，看，我们通常的做法是，如果董事会要求你做这样的事，我们讨论它并一起想出一个解决方案？
Yes.
有。
Somebody said that.
有人那样说。
It definitely has come up a number of times where, this is how we do it. We like to discuss it out.
确实发生了多次，这就是我们做它的方式。我们喜欢讨论它。
And when this has come up, what does she say?
当这种情况发生时，她说什么？
Honestly, it's more lip service, I feel. It's simply, OK, well I understand that that's how you've done it in the past, but we really do need to get this accomplished, and we really do need to get it done. And it's just more of that there's an agenda at hand.
老实说，我觉得这更多是口头上的。很简单，好的，好吧，我明白这是你们过去的做法，但我们确实需要完成它，我们确实需要把它做完。这更多是手头有一个议程。
There were other orders just like the lesson plans, all things that were mandated by the board. All well-meaning. Like the rule that every teacher needed to state, or write on the chalk board, at the beginning of every class, which specific objectives in the state education goals would be met by this particular lesson.
还有其他像教案一样的命令，都是董事会强制要求的。都是好意。比如要求每个老师在每堂课开始时陈述，或者写在黑板上，这堂课将满足州教育目标的哪些具体目标。
They had to be on the blackboard.
它们必须写在黑板上。
Again, Cathy La Luz.
再次，凯西·拉·鲁兹。
I'd have to say, we're covering standard 1A, and we're going to be using prefixes, suffixes, and root words to understand word meanings. That was supposed to be on the blackboard every day.
我不得不说，我们涵盖标准1A，并且我们将使用前缀、后缀和词根来理解词义。那应该是每天写在黑板上的。
As if a seventh grader would care?
好像七年级学生会关心一样？
They didn't care. They didn't care.
他们不在乎。他们不在乎。
Well, what would happen when you would tell them?
好吧，当你告诉他们时会发生什么？
Well, the first time, the kids laughed at me. When they were like, what are you telling us, Miss La Luz?
好吧，第一次，孩子们嘲笑我。当他们像是，你在告诉我们什么，拉·鲁兹小姐？
Cathy says she understands why the school board is asking her to do this. Lots of schools need rules like this.
凯西说她明白校董会为什么要她这样做。很多学校需要这样的规则。
And I know that's true. I know there are terrible teachers out there, and schools in trouble. So when I look at this, I think this is for those schools and those teachers, that they're trying to bring to a more formal standard. They're trying to say, standards matter. Criteria matter. And we want you, teacher, to meet this level of professionalism and teaching. That's what I think they mean. I really don't think this was just supposed to be crazy.
而且我知道这是真的。我知道外面有糟糕的老师，学校陷入困境。所以当我看着这个时，我想这是为了那些学校和那些老师，他们正在努力把学校带向一个更正式的标准。他们试图说，标准很重要。标准很重要。我们想要你，老师，达到这个专业和教学水平。这就是我想他们的意思。我真的不认为这只是为了疯狂。
Right, but the problem is, at this school, you guys are already thinking all the time about how do we become better teachers? What can we do? What's the latest? Every single day you all are thinking that. So you guys are so far ahead of this, and yet they're asking you to go back to the most basic kind of thinking.
对，但问题是，在这所学校，你们一直在考虑我们如何成为更好的老师？我们能做什么？什么是最新的？每天你们都在考虑那个。所以你们遥遥领先于此，但他们却要求你们回到最基础的思维方式。
That's how it feels. And I don't mean to disrespect them. They have a tremendous job. I know there are reasons for the mandates coming down. I know there are teachers who shouldn't be teaching. But we're not that school. We're not those teachers. And we've proved it how many times?
感觉就是这样。我不是要不尊重他们。他们有一项巨大的工作。我知道强制令下来是有原因的。我知道有些老师不应该教书。但我们不是那所学校。我们不是那些老师。而且我们证明了多少次？
Now, if Irving had a more experienced principal when these rules came down, she might have gotten waivers to the rules, or fought the board, or figured out permissible ways around the rules. That's essentially what the two principals before Rita Ortiz, Pat and Madeleine, had done. But Rita was new, and she saw it as her job to enforce the rules. And really, maybe the time had passed in Chicago when any principal could have fought the board on these things. Here's Cathy.
现在，如果欧文小学在这些规则下来时有一位更有经验的校长，她可能已经得到了规则的豁免，或者与董事会抗争，或者找到了绕过规则的可行方法。那基本上是丽塔·奥尔蒂斯之前的两位校长，帕特和玛德琳所做的事情。但丽塔是新人，她认为强制执行规则是她的工作。而且真的，也许芝加哥已经过了任何校长可以就这些事情与董事会抗争的时代。这是凯西。
I remember the last year Madeleine was here, leaving meetings and having teachers say, thank God we have Madeleine. Thank God we have Madeleine. But Madeleine even said to me before she left. We were sitting down at the beginning of her last year, and she said, I'm losing more battles than I'm winning. And she was sad. I'm losing more battles. And I remember looking at her, thinking, oh my God. How much longer will she be with us? And that's when I got scared, realizing that we were going to start being affected by the changes. If Madeleine's saying that, Irving School was not going to be able to stay as protected as we were.
我记得玛德琳在那里的最后一年，离开会议，有老师说，感谢上帝我们有玛德琳。感谢上帝我们有玛德琳。但玛德琳甚至在她离开前对我说了。我们坐在她最后一年开始时，她说，我输掉的战斗比我赢的还要多。她很难过。我输掉的战斗更多。我记得看着她，心想，噢天哪。她还会和我们待多久？那时我感到害怕，意识到我们开始受到变化的影响。如果玛德琳那么说，欧文小学将无法保持我们受到的保护。
We were watching our world crumble.
我们看着我们的世界崩溃。
Again, teacher Heather Madden.
再次，教师希瑟·马登。
I mean, everyone was just so appalled that it wasn't going to be the same, and that everything that they had worked for, for so long. It was just this atmosphere of change.
我是说，每个人都非常震惊，它将不会是一样的，他们工作了这么久的一切。这只是这种变化的气氛。
Why? Describe more, what did it change from, to?
为什么？描述更多，它从什么变到了什么？
There was a lot more commitment on behalf of the teachers beforehand. Teachers would be at Irving until 6:00, 7:00 at night, just working, making sure things were taken care of. Really just pride in what you were doing, and knowing that everything that you were doing was respected. And I think that, quickly, I know, personally, I didn't spend as much time at school. You watched everyone's posture walking around school, and the looks on their faces, and it was a different group of people, just because we were disheartened.
在那之前，老师们投入了更多的精力。老师们会待在欧文小学到晚上6点、7点，只是工作，确保事情被处理好。真的只是为你正在做的事情感到自豪，并且知道你正在做的一切都是被尊重的。而且我认为，很快，我知道，个人来说，我没有在学校花那么多时间。你看着每个人走在学校里的姿态，他们脸上的表情，那是一群不同的人，只是因为我们很沮丧。
When I asked Rita Ortiz about this, she seems to have been oblivious to all of it, especially to the part that was the most important to the teachers, that they were used to making decisions together, with their principal, coming to consensus.
当我问丽塔·奥尔蒂斯关于这件事时，她似乎对此一无所知，特别是对老师们最重要的一部分，即他们习惯于与校长一起做决定，通过共识达成。
I think-- yeah, I'm just thinking right now about what you're saying. And I can't speak for what was before. Perhaps that was more their style of things, and I don't think that I didn't ask.
我想——是的，我正在考虑你说的。我不能代表以前是什么。也许那是他们做事的方式，我不认为我没问。
Did you notice a change in morale, or the number of hours the teachers were working, or anything like that?
你有没有注意到士气的变化，或者老师们工作的时数，或者类似的事情？
I really didn't notice a change in morale. Teachers put in their full days, as far as what I was aware. No, I really didn't notice a change in morale.
我真的没注意到士气的变化。据我所知，老师们全天工作。不，我真的没注意到士气的变化。
By December of last year, Cathy La Luz had had enough. She was tired of seeing things that were effective, like meetings with parents being taken away, and things that just seemed like busy work added to her day.
去年12月，凯西·拉·鲁兹受够了。她厌倦了看到像与家长见面这样有效的东西被拿走，而看起来像是忙碌工作的东西加到了她的一天中。
And I had a moment there. And not just a moment, like a week or two, where I felt like, screw it. You want me to fill out paperwork, I'll fill out paperwork. You want lesson plans, fine. But the time that it's taking me to do this is taking me away from something else, and I'm not going to kill myself to figure out a way to fix that. And we were talking about what's happening next year, I remember it came out of my mouth. I just don't care. Fine. You want me to just hand out a report card? I mean, I had that come out of my mouth, and that's when I thought, I need to quit. I need to leave. If that's how I'm going to be, I can't be teaching anymore if that's what's going to happen.
在那一刻我有一个瞬间。不仅仅是一个瞬间，像一两周，我感觉像是，去它的。你想要我填文书工作，我会填文书工作。你想要教案，好吧。但它花的时间让我脱离了别的事情，我不打算自杀去想办法解决这个问题。我们在谈论明年发生什么，我记得它从我嘴里说了出来。我不在乎。好吧。你想要我只是分发成绩单？我是说，我有那个从我嘴里说出来，那时我想，我需要辞职。我需要离开。如果这就是我要成为的样子，如果那是将要发生的事情，我就不能再教书了。
I would never have thought that that could happen to me. I'm telling you. I mean, that's why I became a teacher. I didn't have a teacher I liked, or felt connected to, or felt anything, all of my grammar school career. Never. High school was a joke for me. I'm not going to be that teacher, that kind of person, the kind of teacher I had. I don't want to be a teacher who just gets done what she has to get done.
我从没想过这会发生在我身上。我告诉你。我是说，这就是我成为老师的原因。我整个小学时期都没有一个我喜欢的、感到连接的或感到什么的老师。从来没有。高中对我来说是个笑话。我不会成为那种老师，那种人，那种我遇到的老师。我不想成为一个只做她必须做的事情的老师。
Not sure what else to do, she wrote a letter to the people who run the school system. "This is my message in a bottle," she wrote. "I throw it out, hoping someone will read it and hear me." She said that the demand for uniformity, for every school to be the same, was chipping away at the things that made Irving a good school in the first place. And given how successful Irving was, couldn't they have more leeway to do things their way, which is what made them a success in the first place? Why fix something that's not broken?
不知道还能做什么，她给管理学校系统的人写了一封信。“这是我瓶子里的信息，”她写道。“我把它扔出去，希望有人会读到并听到我。”她说，对统一的要求，对每所学校都一样的要求，正在削弱让欧文最初成为好学校的东西。考虑到欧文是多么成功，难道他们不能有更多余地用他们的方式做事吗，这正是让他们成功的原因？为什么要修理没坏的东西？
It's like, what did I think was going to happen when I wrote that? Really. I feel sad when I read that. That letter is still full of hope. What's funny is that letter is still full of hope. I feel like a little girl who has been living in a fairy tale, and is waking up to find out, sorry, this is the real world. Because those are the kind of words I'm hearing about our school. You had 10 great years. What are you complaining about? Most schools don't get this.
这就像，写那封信时我以为会发生什么？真的。当我读到它时我感到难过。那封信仍然充满希望。有趣的是，那封信仍然充满希望。我觉得自己像个生活在童话里的小女孩，醒来发现，对不起，这是现实世界。因为那些是我听到的关于我们学校的话。你有10年伟大的生活。你在抱怨什么？大多数学校都没有这个。
That's what the older teachers at her school have been saying to her. Be realistic.
这就是她学校的老老师对她说的话。要现实点。
I've taught only 14 years. We peak out people who have taught 30 years, 28 years, 20 years. And they've seen changes with the board, and different new mandates come down. And so they look at me and they say, you know, things like this have happened before. This is the way it is. You know, Cathy, we were lucky. And now we're going back to the way the rest of Chicago is, and that's the way it is. And this will pass, too, and there'll be another change one day, and there'll be another change, and you just have to roll with the punches. And these are people I respect, and I understand exactly what they're saying. I may not be the kind of person who can do that. That's all. I may not be the kind of person who can just roll with the punches. No. I just don't know I can do that.
我只教了14年。我们挑出教了30年、28年、20年的人。他们看到了董事会的变化，不同的新强制令下来。所以他们看着我说，你知道，像这样的事情以前也发生过。事情就是这样。你知道，凯西，我们很幸运。现在我们要回到芝加哥其余地方的样子了，这就是它的样子。这一切也会过去，总有一天会有另一次变化，会有另一次变化，你只需要随波逐流。这些人是我尊重的，我完全明白他们在说什么。我可能不是能那样做的人。就是这样。我可能不是能随波逐流的人。不。我只是不知道我能那样做。
I suggest to Cathy that she could do what I've seen teachers at lots of other Chicago schools do. Ignore the administration, close your door, and teach.
我建议凯西她可以做我在许多其他芝加哥学校看到的老师做的事情。忽略管理层，关上门，教书。
Yeah. If it wasn't going to effect the structure of my day, I would agree with you, because there's other things that have happened that you just roll off your back. But the changes that are happening are affecting what's happening in the classroom. So I'm going to spend a summer thinking about it.
是的。如果它不会影响我一天的结构，我会同意你，因为还有其他事情发生，你只是置之不理。但正在发生的变化正在影响课堂上发生的事情。所以我打算花一个夏天思考它。
And that's how we left it, at the end of last school year.
这就是我们离开时的情况，在上学年结束时。
Teachers in America are told two contradictory things about their jobs, that they're professionals who know best what's going to work in their own classrooms, and that they're workers, who are there to carry out orders. Do the curriculum the way others set it for them. Obviously in any school system, a teacher is a little bit of each. And at Irving, the fight is basically about where to draw the line.
美国的老师被告知关于他们工作的两件矛盾的事情：他们是知道在他们自己的教室里什么有效的专业人士，他们是去执行命令的工人。按照别人为他们设定的课程去做。显然在任何学校系统中，老师都是这两者的结合。在欧文小学，这场战斗基本上是关于在哪里划清界限。
Even in this era of national education standards, and No Child Left Behind, in theory the idea right now in schools is people at the top set educational goals. Teachers at the bottom should be free to meet those goals, however they see fit. That's a rather delicate thing to manage, especially in a school system the size of Chicago's. It's staggeringly big, nearly a half million kids and teachers, a population equal to New Orleans, or Tucson. In a school system this large, the natural tendency is to want to make everybody do the same thing. It's easier that way.
即使在这个全国教育标准和“不让一个孩子掉队”（No Child Left Behind）的时代，从理论上讲，现在学校的想法是顶层的人设定教育目标。底层的老师应该自由地以他们认为合适的方式达到这些目标。这在管理上是一件相当微妙的事情，特别是在像芝加哥这样规模的学校系统中。它大得惊人，近50万学生和老师，人口相当于新奥尔良或图森。在如此大的学校系统中，自然的趋势是想要让每个人做同样的事情。那样更容易。
What took place at Irving is so common in a big public school system. And the way it took place is so common, that it just happened at a high school not far from Irving, one that was founded on the same kinds of teacher-centered ideas that Irving was. It was called the Best Practice High School. A new principal came in, was under pressure from above to make their school more like other schools, and it wiped out a lot of the curriculum the teachers had designed. Steve Zimmelman is a national figure in what's called the Best Practice Movement, and was one of the founders of this high school. He says he remembers this principal's job interview.
欧文发生的事情在大型公立学校系统中太常见了。它发生的方式太常见了，以至于它刚刚发生在离欧文不远的一所高中，一所建立在欧文那种以教师为中心思想基础上的学校。它被称为“最佳实践高中”（Best Practice High School）。一位新校长来了，在来自上级的压力下要让他们的学校更像其他学校，它摧毁了老师们设计的许多课程。史蒂夫·齐默尔曼（Steve Zimmelman）是所谓“最佳实践运动”的全国性人物，是这所高中的创始人之一。他说他记得这位校长的面试。
We had a candidate that we thought was strong. She said all the right things. And we were fooled by her. I have to admit. It was a terrible mistake. And the moment she got in there, all of a sudden everything changed.
我们有一位我们认为很强的候选人。她说所有正确的话。我们被她骗了。我不得不承认。这是一个可怕的错误。当她进入那里的一瞬间，突然一切都变了。
Did she, in the end, not agree with the basic program of what was going on at the school?
她最终没有同意学校正在进行的基本项目的方案吗？
I don't think so, no. Another thing is that new rules and mandates were coming down from CPS.
我不认为，不。另一件事是新的规则和强制令从芝加哥公立学校（CPS）下来。
CPS. Chicago Public Schools.
CPS。芝加哥公立学校。
And you see good things being erased, and good reform-minded teachers being very unhappy. And they leave.
你看到好的东西被抹去，好的改革心态的老师非常不高兴。然后他们离开。
Yeah. Explain how many of them left.
是的。解释一下他们中有多少人离开了。
It's painful to think about. But all but a few of the-- all but three or four are gone.
想起来很痛苦。但除了少数的——除了三四个，全都没了。
Do you think that could happen at Irving?
你认为这可能发生在欧文小学吗？
I don't know.
我不知道。
What's so crazy about all this is that, officially, the Chicago public school system is in favor of the kind of successful innovation that was happening at that high school, and at Irving. Here's the head of the public school system, Arne Duncan.
这一切最疯狂的是，官方上，芝加哥公立学校系统支持那所高中和欧文小学正在发生的这种成功创新。这是公共学校系统负责人阿恩·邓肯（Arne Duncan）。
What I'm pushing very, very hard is to get away from a one-size-fits-all mentality. Those schools that are very high-performing academically, and that have been fiscally responsible, I actually want to do everything we can to remove any bureaucratic hurdles, and to really give those schools much more flexibility. Really give them their chance to innovate.
我正在非常非常努力推动的是摆脱一刀切的心态。那些在学术上表现非常高，并且在财政上负责任的学校，我实际上想做一切我们能做的事情来消除任何官僚障碍，并真正给予那些学校更多的灵活性。真正给他们创新的机会。
I understand that that's the intent, but I think that what the Irving teachers would tell you is that the times that they've applied for waivers, like with their report card, they were turned down pretty firmly on that.
我明白那是意图，但我认为欧文的老师会告诉你的是，他们申请豁免的时候，比如他们的成绩单，他们被非常坚定地拒绝了。
Right. And I would be happy to take a look at that. I wasn't aware of that situation, and so I can't speak to the specifics. So it may well be a legitimate concern, in that case. Obviously, do we do it perfectly in every situation? Maybe not, and that's where we want to continue to change, and frankly change the culture here, so that it is more supportive of that type of innovation, where it's leading to progress.
对。我很乐意看一看。我不知道那个情况，所以我不能说具体细节。所以那可能确实是一个合法的问题。显然，我们在每种情况下都做得完美吗？也许不是，那正是我们要继续改变的地方，坦率地说，改变这里的文化，以便它更支持那种类型的创新，只要它能带来进步。
I got to say, hearing you say this, I feel like your heart is in the right place. I think the way that things are getting implemented, it's happening in a way that's making a lot of teachers unhappy at this particular school.
我得说，听到你这样说，我感觉你的心是在正确的地方。我认为事情实施的方式，发生的方式让这所特定学校的很多老师不高兴。
Yeah. And again, I don't know all the specifics at that one school. And so where there are issues, I'm absolutely more than happy to look at it, and actually will look at it. Where teachers are really trying to innovate, and take this system to the next level, that's exactly what we want to support. They're doing some great things, in terms of report cards, in terms of spending time with parents. Those might be lessons that really should be informing the entire system, rather than the entire system hurting this.
是的。再次，我不知道那所学校的所有具体细节。所以哪里有问题，我绝对非常乐意看一看，而且实际上会看一看。老师们确实在尝试创新，并把这个系统带到下一个水平，那正是我们想要支持的。他们在做一些伟大的事情，在成绩单方面，在花时间与家长在一起方面。那些可能是应该通知整个系统的教训，而不是整个系统伤害这个。
[PHONE RING]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Hello, Cathy?
喂，凯西？
Yeah.
是的。
Hi, it's Ira Glass.
嗨，我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Hi, Ira Glass.
嗨，艾拉·格拉斯。
How the hell are you?
你到底怎么样？
I'm OK.
我还好。
Well, I'm calling you. It's now the Fall. Summer has passed. Have you got a minute?
好吧，我给你打电话。现在是秋天。夏天已经过去了。你有时间吗？
Yeah.
是的。
So what did you decide?
那么你决定了什么？
Well, I went back. I went back, and it's worse than I thought it would be. I don't see how this is going to work. Every time I get another memo, or another directive. We're being told things about the board saying we have to do this and this and this. You need to do this according to the rules of the board, and I really miss that feeling of being trusted. And it's not there anymore. It really feels like us against them, now. And it's terrible.
好吧，我回去了。我回去了，它比我想象的还要糟。我不明白这将如何运作。每次我收到另一份备忘录或另一份指令。我们被告知董事会的事情，说我们必须做这个和这个。你需要按照董事会的规则做这个，我真的很怀念那种被信任的感觉。它不在了。现在感觉真的像是我们对抗他们。这太可怕了。
Over the summer the new principal, Rita Ortiz, without consulting her teachers, eliminated the hour of planning time Irving teachers get every day. The teachers and parents raised such a fuss in September about it that it's been put back. I tell Cathy that I spoke with her boss' boss' boss' boss, Arne Duncan, head of the school system. And I play her a tape from my interview, him saying that maybe Irving should be allowed to do some of the things that it wants, and that he would look into that. She was skeptical much really come out of it.
夏天，新校长丽塔·奥尔蒂斯在没有咨询她的老师的情况下，取消了欧文老师每天获得的一小时规划时间。老师和家长在9月份为此吵闹得那么凶，它又被放回去了。我告诉凯西我与她老板的老板的老板的老板，校系统负责人阿恩·邓肯谈过。我播放了我采访他的一段录音，他说也许欧文应该被允许做它想做的一些事情，他会调查一下。她对真的会有什么结果持怀疑态度。
I have to say, when I sent that letter, I sent a copy to Arne Duncan. I sent a copy to the next person below him, Barbara Eason-Watkins. And I got a letter saying, basically, sorry. Conformity is what-- using the word-- No. We need coherence throughout the system. And it's a management issue, and I totally understand it. It is a big system. It is hard to monitor a big system.
我不得不说，当我寄出那封信时，我寄了一份给阿恩·邓肯。我寄了一份给下一级的人，芭芭拉·伊森-沃特金斯（Barbara Eason-Watkins）。我收到一封信说，基本上，抱歉。一致性是——用那个词——不。我们需要整个系统的一致性。这是一个管理问题，我完全明白。这是一个大系统。监控一个大系统很难。
Where are you standing this week, on whether or not you're going to stay?
这周你的立场是什么，关于你是否会留下？
Oh, I'm definitely keeping my eyes open. I'm not thinking I'm staying. What I want to do is go. I want to go.
噢，我肯定睁大眼睛看着。我不认为我会留下。我想做的是走。我想走。
When I was an education reporter, I was always struck by how what happened in schools was such an unpredictable mix of real public policy issues and human personality. The chemistry of the teachers, the way they were managed, always seemed like this X-factor, that nobody really talked about, but that seemed to make all the difference in the world. Not that anybody wants to hear that. Even Irving teachers, like Heather Madden. They don't want to hear it.
当我是教育记者时，我总是被学校里发生的事情是现实公共政策问题和人类个性的如此不可预测的混合体所震撼。老师的化学反应，他们被管理的方式，总是看起来像这个X因素，没人真正谈论它，但看起来在世界上造成了所有差异。不是说有人想听那个。即使是欧文的老师，比如希瑟·马登。她们不想听。
It can't just be magic. It can't just be fluky things landing people in the right places, and the chemistry being right. It just can't be that. What's the hope for the rest of the schools? What's the hope for Irving in the future? What's the hope for any school, anywhere?
它不能只是魔法。它不能只是偶然的东西把人落在正确的地方，化学反应是正确的。它不能只是那样。其他学校的希望是什么？欧文未来的希望是什么？任何学校，任何地方的希望是什么？
I do think there's hope. But it has to do with understanding that it is all about personalities. Seeing what's happened lately at Irving, I think, in a way, Madeleine's greatest achievement wasn't that she implemented great reading and writing curriculum. But it was that she made teachers feel in charge. Now that that's gone, it'll be interesting to see if the kids' test scores stay as high. It'll be interesting to see if, by following Chicago public school rules, Irving sinks to the level of the rest of the Chicago public schools.
我确实认为有希望。但它与理解这一切都是关于个性有关。看到最近在欧文发生的事情，我想，在某种程度上，玛德琳最大的成就不是她实施了伟大的阅读和写作课程。而是她让老师感到掌管。现在那消失了，看看孩子的测试分数是否保持那么高将会很有趣。看看通过遵循芝加哥公立学校规则，欧文是否沉沦到芝加哥其他公立学校的水平将会很有趣。
Well, our program was produced today by Wendy Dorr and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Tom Bachmann and Amy O'Leary.
好吧，我们今天的节目是由温迪·多尔（Wendy Dorr）和我自己制作的，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、黛安·库克（Diane Cook）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、莎拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）和丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）。我们的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）运行我们的网站。制作帮助来自汤姆·巴赫曼（Tom Bachmann）和艾米·奥利里（Amy O'Leary）。
[AKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
If you want to offer Cathy La Luz a new job, you can reach her at Washington Irving School in Chicago, Illinois. Transcripts and all the old audio of my old series on the public schools is available for free at our website www.thisamericanlife.org. You can also listen to our programs for free, 24 hours a day, every day of the year. Or you can download audio of our show at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where they have public radio programs, best-selling books, even The New York Times , all at audible.com. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果你想给凯西·拉·鲁兹一份新工作，你可以在伊利诺伊州芝加哥的华盛顿欧文学校联系她。我的关于公立学校旧系列的文字稿和所有旧音频都可以在我们的网站www.thisamericanlife.org免费获取。你也可以每天24小时免费收听我们的节目，全年每一天。或者你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目的音频，那里有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》，都在audible.com。《美国生活》由公共广播国际分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Torey Malatia, who love Kisha dog, but thought Kisha his dog,
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责，他爱基莎狗，但认为基莎是他的狗，
Come to find out the was me Kisha dog.
结果发现那是我的基莎狗。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。